In an era marked by heated claims of
media bias, journalists need to ensure
that news coverage is independent and
impartial. Education, the field I know
best, is one where it should be easy to
meet this bar. To see where things stand,
two colleagues and I analyzed major media
news coverage of federal education in
2009 and 2017. In 2017, Republicans
controlled the federal government and
proposed major new reforms. Back in '09, the same was true of Democrats. In
2017, news stories on Republican
proposals featured a negative slant
nearly half the time. On the other hand,
in '09, coverage of Obama's proposals
tilted negative less than five percent
of the time. This kind of thing might fly
on the editorial pages, but unless one
thinks that Democrats have a monopoly on
educational wisdom, such reporting marks
an abject professional failure. And if
journalists can't even report impartially on education, it's scary to
contemplate how they approach more
polarizing questions.
Do you think major media coverage is biased towards one political party? Let us know in your
comments. Also, let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds, and be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.